joining us now for reaction is a student
from Marjorie Stoneham Douglas high
school and parkland Florida
Brandon manof Brandon thank you for
joining us I know this has been just
beyond horrific a week for students to
you know recover from what they endured
bury their friends try to empathize as
one another and try to learn something
just how are you doing a week after this
you've seen a lot of your fellow
students react a lot of them are very
angry and rightly so but your thoughts
get through it it's been a pretty
I wouldn't say good but I've been
getting through it have some rocky
moments but I'm managing
Brandon you made a reference yesterday
of the day before to what the media had
been doing to like push an agenda
throughout this tragedy I'm gonna play a
series of media comments about what
happened and get your reaction on the
other side let's watch this is a new
start with a kind of a you know a new
group of activists who might have some
impact we have a new greatest generation
the strength the the power the emotion
the take action attitude of those
students it's a youth movement that time
this time it's going to be different you
know at other times we see lawmakers say
it's too soon we can't talk about it but
because of social media these students
have said don't speak for me I want to
talk about it I want to go to Washington
I want to go to Tallahassee Brandon your
reaction to that
I definitely think it's a youth movement
but I feel like not all the youth is
being listened to feel like the
conservative side of it is being ignored
it's just pushing gun control did you
happen to see Andrew Pollock today who
spoke about his daughter Cheyenne who
died and his three sons were standing
with him at the White House and he
basically said yeah there's a time you
don't have a conversation about guns you
have a conversation but right now we got
to make sure these schools are equipped
to handle these types of attacks you
could tell he was really annoyed it
seemed but what he was hearing about
yeah let's go after the guns they are
whatever the gonna they say the gun of
choice is he found that to be an
unhelpful part of the conversation and
all day my producers and I were
wondering are there any students out
there who you know maybe think focusing
on that issue almost exclusively is the
wrong approach and your answer to that
would be it's definitely the wrong time
to be speaking about it still it's been
a week we're still mourning the loss of
our loved ones then they're just still
talking about what kind of guns out log
out long guns the kind of laws to create
but 17 people just died at the hands of
a human human controlled guns
Brandin the assistant football coach
died and another brave act of
selflessness and self-sacrifice and I
know you're on the football team how is
the team doing given what you guys as
individuals have suffered the friendship
you had with coach Aaron and how are you
doing people are managing it's a sad
situation to know that he's gone he was
a great man great leader always
enjoyable to be around and talk to
cracking jokes helping everybody out I'm
just sad to know that he's gone I won't
be able to use his mentorship anymore
how do you think school will be when you
return to campus I guess next week after
there'll be a week of more I guess
protests in Tallahassee I think we have
some of the audio of what happened today
with some of your fellow students
I guess quite a few hundreds I showed up
in Tallahassee chanting they're gonna
vote vote various legislators out who
don't vote for particular bands it got
pretty heated and they you know they
were screaming and and you know very
very upset but I didn't hear
I didn't hear a lot of diversity of
thought I heard mostly one side
it doesn't seem like they're looking to
hear from the other side it's two sides
every store but they only want to hear
one what would what would you say the
makeup of the student body is
politically is it pretty diverse or is
it split down the middle or could you
not even tell I personally feel as
diverse I have friends who are on both
sides of the situation it's in a very
diverse area two different cities close
to another County it's just definitely
diverse Zach Lesk
of student at your school said the
following about the situation oh sorry
about that it's a full screen he said we
can't have people walking around with
automatic weapons they're made for mass
murder and you know obviously automatic
weapons are been banned since about
almost a hundred years ago so the air 15
is not an automatic weapon but that
Cystic I mean if you're not familiar
with guns if you don't know then that's
what kind of people think and believe
and I feel bad for a lot of these kids
because they just they don't mean I
didn't know anything about this when I
was 15 and 16 years old
I just didn't know yeah but I feel like
they're uninformed they're just
following along the popular opinion but
they clearly don't know what they're
talking about
Brandon we wish you the best and thank
you for having the courage to speak out
at a time where it seems that the
diversity of thought isn't all that well
showcase so we really appreciate your
time tonight thank you so much and God
bless you and the students at desert
side thanks so much thank you